if you race wine you know the value of
quality feed and the importance of
disease prevention during grain
production harvest transport and storage
feed exposed to moisture can be
contaminated with toxins as byproducts
of fungal growth a prime example is the
mycotoxin Zarrella known Zarrella known
molecules accumulate around moulds
growing on the feed subsequent ingestion
of these toxic particles can cause Mico
toxicosis resulting in devastating
livestock health problems and production
losses understanding my co toxicosis
begins by following a mycotoxins journey
through the animal's digestive system
digestion starts in the stomach where
the gastric juices release the ceralun
own molecules from the feed and the
toxins get dispersed into the digester
from there the tucks and molecules move
down the gastrointestinal tract into the
small intestine along with nutrients the
mycotoxin are absorbed through the
intestinal wall the toxin molecules and
feed nutrients are carried into the
blood where they are predominantly
metabolized by the liver the toxic
metabolites travel throughout the body
Sarala known primarily affects the
reproductive organs impairing ovulation
and causing systemic inflammation the
toxin can cause in large mammary glands
reduced fertility and male feminization
in sows ceralun own can cause the vulva
to swell vaginal and rectal prolapse
enlarged uterus and shrunken ovaries the
effects of mycotoxins are not always
obvious to the naked eye as compared
with a healthy Pig and affected pigs
reproductive system is functionally
compromised enlargement of the
reproductive organs is a symptom of the
estrogenic response to Zarrella known
which becomes detrimental to the
reproductive performance of the animal
and in these cases a decrease in
reproductive efficiency invariably means
economic loss for the producer
proper feed and grain storage and
cleanliness are only one step in
preventing mycotoxins from affecting
your swine Amblin products offer an
added line of defense the unique clay
mineral in Amblin products rapidly
captures the mycotoxins this prevents
the toxin from entering the blood here's
how it works
when the mycotoxin molecules enter the
stomach through contaminated feed they
are quickly absorbed by the clay
particles the porous structure of the
Amblin clay and its natural affinity for
the mycotoxin makes it the perfect enter
o sorbent when the clay toxin complexes
move through the small intestine the
mycotoxin stay bound to the clay
preventing them from being passed into
the blood as a result ambulance and rose
sorbents reduce the mycotoxin
concentrations in the blood helping to
keep your swine healthy and productive
the mycotoxin and clay are later
excreted harmlessly in the feces Emlyn
entro sorbents are a powerful barrier
against maiko toxicosis
you